-Tariq, we have a lot to get to.
The book is available finally.
Right now. You can get it.
Go to any bookstore,
local bookstore.
You can go
to Barnes & Nobles.
Whatever you got to do.
-Wherever books are sold.
-Wherever books are sold, you
can get "The Upcycled Self."
Congratulations, by the way,
on your 11th Grammy nomination,
as well.
-Thank you.
-I mean, this is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got nominated for your song
"Love Letters,"
which is a tribute to hip-hop.
-To hip-hop, yeah.
A love letter to hip-hop
in celebration of,
you know, its 50th anniversary,
as well as
my 50th anniversary here.
-Yeah. That's true.
That's right. Happy birthday.
Happy...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-The -- A lot of it's
in the book of how you got
started in hip-hop and rap.
Was it your cousin? Shawn?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, Shawn and I.
Well, you know Shawn,
who's now the Roots' manager.
You know, my long-time,
you know, competitor.
Yeah. We started --
-Was he?
-Yeah, he's about
two years older than me.
And when we were young,
we would always compete
just with the --
first with, you know, sketching
and, like, visual art,
and then it sort of,
you know, elevated
into writing songs out of
our encyclopedias and stuff.
We used the encyclopedia,
dictionaries and stuff
and write rhymes.
So, you know, he got nice.
I think I started at around 9,
and by the time I was 11
and he was 13 or so,
he made a record.
He had, like, a piece of vinyl
that was pressed up,
and, you know,
so then that became
my life's mission, was,
you know, just getting better
than he was on that record.
-What was -- Do you remember
one of your first rhymes?
-Of course. Well,
I've done my first rhyme.
I did it here, you know,
as a guest on the couch before.
It's -- It was written that,
you know --
You know the style
of J.J. Fad, "Supersonic"?
Where it's like,
you know, just...
Summa-lumma-lumma-lumma-lumma...
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So I did --
I'd written one of those.
And, yeah,
the rest is sort of history.
-Yeah.
And before you were the Roots,
you were the Square Roots,
right?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Who came up with that name?
-I think I came up
with the Square Roots.
I think I thought of the logo
first, like, you know,
this is what could represent
the Square Roots.
And it was sort of like,
you know, the square root,
that little check thing,
and I had the root underneath
the, you know --
under the umbrella.
-Yeah. Yeah.
And that didn't stick?
-No, it didn't stick.
It didn't stick.
But, I mean, you know,
it stuck long enough for us
to get our first merch
pressed up.
You know, I think we did a gig
for someone,
and they paid us in T-shirts.
They paid us
in Square Roots T-shirts.
-I'll take it, man.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Did you have any other names
for the band
besides Square Roots?
-Yeah, yeah.
You know, we were Radioactivity
at one point.
I think, you know,
we also entertained the idea
of calling ourselves,
like, Soul Fish or something.
I don't know. But it didn't --
-Soul Fish?
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Soul Fish?
-It was what --
-Imagine if you were called
Soul Fish.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I don't think --
I don't think that band
would have meant,
you know, what the Roots mean
to the culture.
-No. Not Soul Fish.
-Right.
-Was Black Thought
always your name?
-Nah. Come on.
And you know it wasn't.
You know Black Thought
wasn't always my name.
[ Drum roll ]
What was my name, Jimmy?
-Oh, my God. It's so good.
There's two of them.
There's one that's okay,
and there's one that's awful.
[ Laughter ]
One was called, like,
T Metaphor or something.
-Yeah. Yeah. T Metaphor.
-T Adjective.
-[ Laughs ] T Adjective.
-Yeah. Any Mad Lib.
T Metaphor.
-Yes. Yeah. Yeah. T Metaphor.
That was one of them.
That was one.
-Yeah. T Meta?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and then you had
something called, like --
I want to say Hawk Smooth?
-It was Hawk Smooth.
Yeah. It was an acronym.
[ Laughter ]
It was an acronym.
-It was an acronym?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It stood for -- It was
the Hype African Warrior
Kickin' it Smooth.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Like --
-Good God!
-You know.
-Wow!
That's a long walk on that one.
Oh, my --
Dude, imagine if you were
Hawk Smooth from Soul Fish.
[ Laughter ]
Hawk Smooth from Soul Fish
sounds like some dude --
Like, he works security at,
like, one of those
outdoor festivals
hoping to get recognized
when he's like,
"Right this way.
Gotta have your pass."
You go,
"Yo, is that Hawk Smooth?
-"Is that Hawk Smooth
from Soul Fish?"
-"No pictures, man.
Come on, man."
-Yeah, man.
-I love the book.
I love the stories.
-Thank you.
-I didn't know this much about
you there. It's a great story.
And it's funny obviously because
you have a great sense of humor,
but it's a lot of stuff, man.
You really worked your way
to get to where you are.
-Yeah, yeah, for sure, for sure.
-What does
"The Upcycled Self" mean?
-I think "The Upcycled Self"
is about just arriving
at a better version of oneself
and, like,
whatever that journey,
you know, sort of includes.
For me, you know, it's been
a personal trajectory
and it's been about addressing
and unpacking a lot
of the trauma of the past,
you know, and stuff
that, you know,
even my closest friends
didn't know about me
because I don't wear it
on my sleeve.
But, yeah, I think
at this stage of the game
at this point in my career
and, you know, at this point
in the Roots' career,
I think we --
the idea is to be of service.
Right? You know?
So I feel like, you know,
addressing this sort of thing
and, you know, just speaking
to my history in this way
is what's better --
what's going to best serve
my long-time fans
and supporters, you know?
Yeah, I would meet people
who, you know,
said some of the same thing,
in that,
"Yo, I've rocked with you
for such a long time.
Long-time fan.
I felt like I knew you.
I know your music.
But, you know, I didn't."
-And I like the idea
of upcycling.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It's not recycling. but it's...
-Upcycling. Yeah. You don't
have to abandon everything.
You know, there's a quote from
Bruce Lee that says, you know,
"Adapt that which is useful,
abandon that which is not,
and add that which is uniquely
and specifically your own."
And I feel like
that's the upcycle, you know?
-Yeah. Yeah. I love it.
I think it's gonna inspire
a lot of people.
I have to ask --
because I've been asking
for the last five, seven years.
When are we getting
a new Roots album?
-Ooh. Uh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look --
-Questlove's peeking
over the cameras.
-Right. Right.
I can say, you know,
the new Roots album is coming,
you know, hopefully soon.
But I mean, you know,
let's just put --
let's put folks on the spot.
Ahmir, when's the new
Roots album coming?
-Hey, man!
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-It's done when it's perfect.
-Wow.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Well, this is perfect.
Congratulations. This is done.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-"The Upcycled Self"
is available now.
Tariq Trotter, everybody!
Go pick it up.
More "Tonight Show" after the
break. Stick around, everybody.